you're ready for an adventure why not do
it safely and in style
subaru of las vegas can help
subarus are known for their durability
you know what i go into
stores all around the community and
people see my subaru badge and they want
to start talking and tell me their
subaru story
you know and so they're just a long
lasting vehicle uh
97 percent of the of the vehicles
subaru's sold in the last 10 years
are on the road today they've got a
great reputation secondly i think that
it would be
a versatility with the subaru
symmetrical all-wheel drive you know you
can just take those things
almost anywhere and then lastly i think
and this is probably the most important
is they're so safe burton so i'm ready
for an adventure i think we're all ready
for some adventure but
i need to do it with style absolutely
i'm noticing this red trimming and this
very cool sports vehicle
yeah this is the the 2021 subaru
forester sport i love
it it is beautiful look at this is this
that red and orange trim carries in onto
the interior
this one is equipped with navigation it
has a panoramic
moon roof you have paddle shifters uh
for that sporty nature that the car has
can i turn it on you can
push to start smooth the the seat
material is washable so you can take it
uh
back in the in the out country you know
and and you can wash the interior
it's just really a beautiful vehicle you
love the way this drives i love it and i
love the way it looks
and of course most importantly i feel
safe yes
that is the best part is you know that
you're going to make it to your
destination
safely subaru has continued to develop
the
the forester and the 2021 model is even
better than it's ever been before
our eyesight accident avoidance system
is
has been enhanced our driver focus uh
is is something that's new to the subaru
forester and uh it keeps
a look at your eyes to see if you're
getting sleepy when you're on the road
and it'll alert you to wake up a pull
over
take a nap it's just an amazing
all-around vehicle
people equate the all-wheel drive system
is something that's just for the snow
all-wheel drive is is something for any
surface so
you know we get the occasional rain and
lately it's been very occasional
when that happens cars seem to skid out
here a lot with subaru with the
symmetrical all-wheel drive
it it provides you a real good road grip
so dry wet snow mud
your limitations are lifted you don't
have to just stay in the city
you can choose to go to the mountain you
can go to the lake you can take it
off-road and yet it's a great all-around
daily driver it's comfortable
it's safe
give subaru of las vegas a call at
702-4952
or visit subaru of las vegas dot com and
they have a special offer right now
zero percent apr financing on select
2021 models
las vegas now we'll be right back